vous connaissez le questionnement qui se
posent sur le baccalauréat organisées le
baccalauréat
cette quelque chose de massif tous les
gens qui participent à l'organisation du
baccalauréat savent que chaque année
c'est un exercice considérable
d'impression de définition des sujets
une énorme machinerie qui prend beaucoup
de temps et qui commence très tôt le
confinement rend très délicat bhl
l'organisation dans des conditions
normales du baccalauréat très délicat
matériellement et j'allais dire très
délicat presque
comment dire pédagogiquement puisque par
définition les conditions d'enseignement
sont dégradées réel et encore une fois
je le salue l'engagement des enseignants
mais dégradé par rapport à ce qui est la
norme et donc il nous paraît je le dis
parce que j'en ai beaucoup discuté avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
pendant toute la semaine il nous paraît
délicat d'imaginer que l'on puisse faire
comme si de rien n'était et imaginer que
le bac ce 2020 2020 se passerait dans
des conditions normales je ne crois pas
aux jours où nous parlons qu'il puisse
se passer dans des conditions normales
comme si de rien n'était il n'est pas
raisonnable d'imaginer cela il faut donc
étudier et c'est ce qui est en train
d'être fait par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale les conditions
dans lesquelles le bac 2020 peut être
organisé plusieurs options sont sur la
table il y a ceux qui disent organisons
le parent contrôle continu et assumons
le fait que cette année c'est le
contrôle continu qui doit prévaloir
entièrement il ya ceux qui disent
essayons de conserver la possibilité
d'organiser une épreuve beaucoup d'idées
sont réunis beaucoup d'idées sont
formulés beaucoup de contraintes
s'applique à nous il est bien évident
que cette question est assez fortement
liée aux conditions dans lesquelles nous
allons procéder aux déconfinement et
donc est soumise à beaucoup d'inconnues
celle que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
le ministre est en train avec ses
services de consulter et d'instruire les
solutions qui sont envisageables et
j'aurai l'occasion avec lui de
m'exprimer prochainement pour dire quel
est le sens de la décision que nous
prenons
mais vous imaginez bien que il est
désormais acquis
qu'il ne sera pas possible d'organiser
dans les conditions normales le bac 2020